We'd used what is
essentially a children's toy,
basically silly putty
and we’d added a very,
very small amount of graphene.
to give a composite material with
useful sensing properties.
When you took the composite,
the silly putty with graphene in it
and you squashed it or
deformed it in anyway,
its electrical resistance
would change dramatically.
the electrical resistance change
for a normal strain sensor would be,
there is a sensitivity factor which is two,
and two is good, two
is fine, for a lot of applications.
Our sensors had sensitivity
factors of up to 500
so we knew immediately that
we had something interesting.
There are actually really important
applications based on this.
So, for example, if you take the composite
and you mounted it on the chest cavity of
a person, eh, it will, the resistance of the
composite will change as they breathe,
as their chest expands and contracts
so you can measure breathing and
actually that's important
in areas in in medical diagnostics for example
in cough death or in certain conditions, like
sleep apnea, you can measure
them by measuring breathing
but there's a much more important
application we feel and
that's monitoring of pulse
So pulse is known to be a wellness indicator
- if you're ill, your pulse will change.
So we found that when the sensor is
held up here to the carotid artery
that, that pulsing of that artery
can actually be detected
and can be read out in an electrical resistance change.
So we can measure the pulse, which gives a
measure of the heart rate,
but the sensor is sensitive enough
that we can also get the
blood pressure out of that
and that's actually quite important.
We can measure blood pressure, of course we
can,
but it's not straightforward
to measure it continuously
and that's what
this sensor can do so
we believe that there will be a
lot of applications in medical devices
and for example in diagnostics.
And so it really shows the
power of nanomaterials -
a small amount of nano can really turn the
ordinary into something extraordinary.